[Music]
in parental dress code News submitted by
Amazon boxes a high school's new dress
code for parents has people very annoyed
that was wondering what that was for I
know so many of them okay so what
happens now do I look at the clothes
this is my first one yeah we just listen
to oh yeah we just hear the article oh
do I have to I don't have to read the
whole guide and then we get the chavies
just react to her article yeah let's go
home
so this high school in Houston they this
one principal warned parents that they
will be turned away from the school if
they show up to the school wearing hair
rollers leggings silk bonnets or any
other items on the list of banned
clothing hair rollers so you can't show
her things yeah you can't show up uh if
you're not ready like outside ready yeah
I can't go in PJs what about leggings
doll no leggings
that's not know me what is that
considered like so it says leggings that
are showing your bottom and where your
body is not covered from the front or
back that's too sexy will not be some
people wear leggings that you can see
through them and I'm like oh I mean I
guess then but at the same time like I
would never be able to survive at the
school a hot-ass girl does know some
know but they're talking about parents
Oh the parent can't realize the parents
cannot show up that way that foot in the
building if they're just in any any of
it so it's oh my gosh thank you no kids
right like pajamas hair rollers shower
caps satin cat bonnet what's up mom
first of all a bond aside like if they
meet you were like in the 1800's that
you put over your head that looks like a
shower I was a bonnet first of all I
want to meet the person that showed up
that way that made this rule like I want
I want to meet I want to be friends with
her
like I want I want and be like okay
listen I love your parenting I think we
need to swap different stories or
recipes or something know what it is
right yeah a bonnet yeah you sold those
yeah you didn't chop a fire in your back
my parents on the black you supply store
Oh awesome I love that okay so you have
the hook-up yeah for the next meeting a
couple more years see you don't show up
to your kids school like that right no
okay she can she's a celebrity now oh
the judge her I want to if I kids I
would show up in a clown outfit a pirate
were you the most popular girl she
dresses the clown is a part-time job no
so at the time she was a preschool
teacher and so she dressed up like as a
day for their like for the student huh
that's crazy
Yeah right I went to Christian School my
for and I was home-schooled at the very
end of it but like they were so strict
about like what you had to wear like all
of this skirts had to be below the knee
and then my stepmom showed up to a
Christmas thing and girls were not
allowed to wear pants and my stepmom
showed up in pants and they're like that
wasn't really rebellious though that
wasn't a clown outfit like it wasn't
nearly as cool just pick me up from
school in a clown outfit cuz there was
just like that day at her school she
just did oh she did do it for you oh
just like MOBAs it's so embarrassing I
think I was in the third grade I never
got embarrassed by my parents ever like
when boy are you the embarrassing my dad
like this you never had that moment when
you're like can you walk like a block
away while I'm walking with my friend I
was I was [ __ ] that is [ __ ] I wanted
to pick me up at the front immediately
because my dad hated going to the front
to pick me up because II had to wait in
the line of cars so he made me walk all
the way over there so I'd be upset but
just [ __ ] picnic
oh that's so funny though that's so fun
I think my mom had to explain my
personality to a lot of people before we
started like before I was in a group set
she's like just so you know like my
daughter's a little different you know
she's a little weird a little quirky you
know I was like always in my own little
world like creating things and you know
doing my own little bit you know a
little a little weird release your mom
prep them
yeah just through me she's like [ __ ]
like Olympic athlete my parents would
drop me off at the beach every summer
just me my friends and we're like only
fourth graders really yeah creators
fourth fifth graders did you do
something bad where did you get into
trouble I mean like I think their idea
of safety was a lot different no
seriously because they're from Japan and
when you're out there you're like five
or six years old and you're already
independent riding the train you're
going to school yourself you're hanging
out with your friends so then when I
tell them I want to go to the beach with
my friends they'll just drop me off and
they don't think anything of it
that's awesome yeah but I got a lot of
Independence that way yeah I don't live
in fear that's a good way to grow up
though yeah you know you don't want to
be like worried about everything yeah
but then now I think back I'm like damn
I could have been a duck there's some
yeah whatever
like what were you thinking parents you
know I have that thought a lot okay I'm
not looking at your computer I just want
you to know that I don't feel like I am
I just wanted you to know I appreciate
know anyway so back to the high school
here so they're saying a lot of people
are very upset of his new policy because
some people are saying like you know
this this I want to look like trash at
school because parent you know the
reason why the women wear the satin cap
since those cuz they just they haven't
done their hair done and it's pricey to
get their hair done and so they're
saying like not everyone can afford to
live up to these standards and they've
placed now on everyone y'all go to
[ __ ] school even dude tell my kid to
do that [ __ ] I'm just dropping a dumbass
off yeah what about if you have alopecia
or something and you want to put a wrap
you know in your head
how this all started this one parent was
taking they were taking their child to
school and the parent was wearing a
t-shirt dress with a scarf like around
her head scarf
yeah and so they refused to let her
inside the school and then so she was
asking like where in anywhere in this
like the school policy does it say that
I can't walk in this way and the the
school administrators they couldn't
provide any proof for her and she
refused to leave and they ended up
calling the cops yeah so then she was
like what the hell like how did this
like how did this happen you know like
I'm coming here if it was for my
religion and I had a headscarf like how
dare you tell me I can't wear yeahit's
car if it wasn't for her religion she's
just saying like if it was that's very
discriminatory yeah and let my religion
is lazy let me [ __ ] come in here
comfortable because I woke up late and I
had to rush and drop off my kids yeah I
should the school have any say in how
you dress parents yeah that's what a lot
of people are saying in the school are
saying quote we are preparing your child
for a prosperous future now what brings
on a prosperous future no yeah so
they're saying that it begins here so
you should be the best example for your
child I'll be I'll be whatever [ __ ]
example I want to be if I want to be a
piece of [ __ ] that's my choice yeah well
I can't control what is your aesthetic
have to do anything with how you are as
a person I guess is my quick like real
mom always actually just woke up
explains you're Hispanic I wonder if our
parents and our grandparents had just
more time because everyone looked sharp
like they wouldn't be caught outside
wearing my bed it's also the communities
were a lot smaller and everyone was
talking [ __ ] about everyone so there was
more accountability yeah yeah yeah so
now what is it they don't give a [ __ ]
now it's like you worry about other [ __ ]
I think we have too much going on and I
think the the accessibility of having
cameras everywhere cameras on our phones
you know what I mean I just feel like
that could be but maybe a part of it but
the
feel classier the fall the parents came
it does regular clothes instead of like
fuzzy slippers and that's a bunny [ __ ]
now I like the fuzzies liberated that
right and I and I would like to consider
myself an open minded individual that
would be like Walter do whatever you
want on your time and and I can
appreciate what the school is trying to
do right like they're trying to see it
as all we're helping set up like a
bright future for these students to be
respectable and self respected or
whatever but yeah but to start
controlling the parent is that's just
weird to me I'm like where's the line
cuz I feel like the party starts home
and I spend my money now the part that I
feel like I'm I'm on the side of the
school is they're only saying you could
be as bumpy as you want if you just drop
off the kid but if you want to step foot
on our campus in an atmosphere we're
trying to create the better your kids
then you got to get with our program too
yeah because that's what I'm getting
from it like we're trying to make like
don't get it don't get it wrong parents
we're doing this for your kids yeah so
if you can be a leader at home for your
kids it helps our job makes that easier
to make would you say oh cuz then cuz
the other thing is you can't just coming
onto campus yeah that's what I'm taking
like you just want to talk to my mom
instead of the rules they should just
use good old-fashioned like bullying and
when they walk in like the teacher
should you just [ __ ] wake up and
start laughing up in designated parent
bullies yeah
every morning digit administrators
they're just roasting parents oh my god
all the students are watching this -
yeah this is all reminds me of Kevin
Hart's dad you're gonna learn today like
when he shows up
did you guys ever hear that like it's
the end of it we're like he's like hi
and he shows up at a spelling bee and
like sweatpants with no drawers on
that's like you gotta learn today I wish
that would have felt embarrassment no I
don't I can't empathize with that you
wouldn't be embarrassed
I was never ever embarrass my mom ever
as a mother of farted in front of her
friends [ __ ] weird dude like my mom
would never walk into a class fart in
the middle I look at you and say I have
indigestion what you
oh I love her I love people that are
just honestly themselves you know what I
mean obviously trying to ruin your whole
[ __ ] career do you have friends at
all that's [ __ ] intense it's natural
yes a lot of people are saying that this
this particular dress code against the
parents is kind of messed up because
this is only for one school in the whole
district in this one school it has 58%
of his students are Hispanic and 40% are
african-american they all have head
wraps all the time yeah you saw that
[ __ ] all the time dude no they're just
saying like it just seems like you know
you're just unfair I mean if they talk
to all the parents and then this was
like a decision that they made together
I think it would be different that's
true because the parents might be like
oh you know what that makes sense let's
all do our best to dress better and
front of the kids and all that versus
like them trying to parent the parent
now it's more of a ego or pride issue or
something yeah that feels weird where is
the school again
Houston Oh Houston where's Texas yes no
is there a Texas Georgia rivalry there
that I'm sensing southern you know like
they care about that stuff in the south
you know what I mean it's all about
presentation and never about like you
know the Christian stuff that we were
talking about earlier where it's all
fake yeah I grew up around that yeah
yeah just like one little thing off and
they think you're the devil yeah and
it's like come on yeah that's what this
is reminding me of the same theme
[Music]